[Musique]
les sports seysses à des jeunes
aventures d'affrontements deux
simulations encore de la réalité
virtuelle un univers digital ludique et
très varié qui réunit les petits et les
grands avec un objectif se dépasser les
jeunes générations mais on va s'adapter
ce qu'il faut pas laisser nos enfants
soudés mais choses qu'on ne maîtrise
plus ça devant une fois le beau jouer
correctement et l entraînement et du
temps en martinique et la communauté des
gamers n'en finit pas de croître et
draine avec elle un grand nombre
d'opportunités que certains comme alaïs
plus connu sous le pseudo de leyio ont
transformé en profession aux talents
reconnus qui fait de ce pro gamers l'un
des dix meilleurs français sur le jeu
street fighter 5 avec cette année un
challenge tout particulier à mon niveau
jamais dit aussi que j'ai je pense avoir
des chances de pouvoir y arriver mais il
faut que je me donne les moyens et pour
me donner les moyens
eh bien il faut que je puisse
effectivement m'entraîner sans relâche
afin de pouvoir parvenir dans l'une des
deux équipes qui seront disponibles pour
les jeux olympiques en 2020 et qui aura
lieu bien sûr au japon un potentiel
martiniquais qui intéresse de nombreux
professionnels du secteur exemple avec
le pari ce gaming school qui propose des
formations diplômantes reconnu par
l'état qui ouvrent les portes vers toute
une série de métiers dans ce domaine
d'activité en plein essor si vous n'avez
peut-être pas ce talent s'il ya
énormément de métiers qui gravitent
autour de l'iss porte et qui peuvent
vous permettre de vous exprimer dans
votre passion et surtout de construire
un projet professionnel
à partir de cette passion que ce soit
les managers les coachs pour là pour
s'occuper des joueurs que ce soit les
communicants comme les des journalistes
spécialisés des community managers pour
et après vous avez aussi toute une
partie de production des chefs de projet
des régisseurs des techniciens et on a
besoin de tout ça de tous ces métiers
afin de créer des sports et de de le
développer
on attendant l'émergence d'une filière
histoire en martinique les puristes ont
pu se régaler sur d'anciens concepts qui
même sans écran n'ont pas pris une ride